crypto nft blog chain man hört momentan
nichts anderes und gefüllt ist jeder in
irgendeiner weise investiere skip toni
zukunft die marktkapitalisierung ist
über die letzten jahre bis heute auf ein
all time high von über zweieinhalb
millionen dollar gestiegen es kommen
täglich neue tokens auf den markt und
hätte man vor einem jahr 1000 euro in
deutschland investiert wären sie heute
260.000 565 euro wert das thema
verspricht eine revolution wie sie
zuletzt durchs internet gesehen haben um
gleichzeitig eine möglichkeit schnelles
geld zu verdienen aber wie schwer ist es
selber teile aufwand zu werden und nicht
nur crypto zu kaufen sondern selber zu
erstellen es kommt ne kiste
wir haben zehn millionen bevor wir mit
dem video starten wenn ich das ganze
gefällt lass mir gerne leichter wenn
dieses video über 30.000 likes bekommt
dann werde ich probieren mit einer
eigenen währung zu rolex zu kommen für
eine rolex trennung folgt am anfang
einer jeder großen idee steht kein
produkt sondern einen marketingplan so
traurig das ist mittlerweile scheint es
wirklich so zu sein
wir müssen verkaufen auch bei einer club
tour bilden bevor wir uns also um die
erstellung dieser crypto währung kümmern
braucht er als allererstes einen
marketingplan ein marketing video eine
website und leute die vertrauenswürdig
sind um diese kultur währung zu
verkaufen und braucht noch namen also
jeder millionär zu werden
[Musik]
das ist so träsch dass das muss
funktionieren welche leute auf die
website gehen und das sehen keiner wird
auch nur einen cent investieren oder
alle werden oder alle oder alle um
diesen wunderbaren namen den wir gerade
erfunden haben und wenn ihr gleich hören
werdet werden wir jetzt eine website auf
der wir das video einbinden auf der wir
alle unsere vorteile dieser clip
bewährung oder dieses topfes einbinden
ich habe da schon eine idee wie stab mit
dem werbevideo wir brauchen eine menge
stock footage um uns mit den ganzen
anderen startup videos einzureihen eine
vernünftige synchronstimme und ein video
in dem viel gesprochen wird aber nichts
gesagt das kann ich sehr gut und david
starten wir
crypto aber verständlich sicher und
transparent kein schnickschnack einfach
nur billig dezentralisierte revolution
im finanzbereich ein schritt in die
zukunft nachhaltig fast eine komplette
lüge das war wird eine sache gibt die
krippe nicht ist dann nachhaltig
kapiteln bieten wir sind alle gleich des
was hier getrieben
gut aber wir brauchen auch noch ein
synchronsprecher damit beim video haben
das auch in irgendeiner weise verkauft
brauchen wir ein wenig professionalität
wenn wir schon in dem video nicht sagen
um nur leere versprechungen machen dann
muss es wenigstens dabei gut aussehen
und sich gut anhören
deswegen darauf war und suchen einen
synchronsprecher liegt es für ahlmann
unter andere leute professioneller in
sachen auf englisch sind ja weil sie
weniger verstehe ich als kind nicht
professionell wenn die irgendwie negativ
sagt iris unseren köln ist der da will
das ist alles wieder raus und ihren
reist gehen der klassischen
ausgangsstellung für den schmetterball
ich bin ja google und uwe auch nicht
ihre stimme für alle projekte für die
sieger david so jetzt wissen uns noch
überlegen was er sagt es muss auf jeden
fall viel gesprochen werden ohne dass
sachen gesagt werden dass nämlich
grundsätzlich so bei irgendwelchen
crypto marketing videos das geht so ein
bisschen fast in irgendwelche karl s
richtungen genau das brauchen wir
untersetzung jetzt dran
wir haben die brainstorm und getextet
was das zeug hält um keine leeren
versprechen auszulassen um das video
möglichst authentisch scheiße wirken zu
lassen sich sogar hast du den einstieg
in deutsche post hatte den einstieg ins
bild kommt verpasst dann sei dieses mal
schaun investiert alles was du hast
wir haben komplett meter text für den
voice over artist geschrieben wir
schicken jetzt ab und dann können wir
damit mal ein paar aufnahmen von
greenster natur ein paar aufnahmen aus
der stadt die das schnelle leben neue
technologien und so weiter zeigen und
dann sollte das werbevideo
schon fertig sein aber wie sieht unser
kreul eigentlich was werden auf dem
konto auch sein
eigentlich muss es ja ein anhaltspunkt
geben bei dem die leute sich wieder
sicher wenn sie dann so weit sind und
dem kreuz vor sich sehen und ihn kaufen
wollen wir brauchen unseren
vertrauenswürdigsten sales partner
was würde da besser funktionieren als
ein profilbild bei dem ich so aussehen
[Musik]
wir haben die synchronsprecher dateien
bekommen wir haben uns topfit geholt und
ich habe leo damit beauftragt die
krasseste werbung für diesen klein zu
schneiden um vertrauen zu erwecken bei
den leuten und um den leuten zu sagen
was unser crm kann und was wir brauchen
ich werde mir jetzt zum allerersten mal
die werbung anschauen in einer welt die
vom wandel der zeit eingeholt wird
bringen wir die lösung für alle
finanzprobleme ein dezentrales vor dem
alle menschen gleich sind
bei dem keine bank einfluss nehmen und
mit dem das geld wirklich dir gehört
smart einfach und zukunftssicher sind
wörter die man selten mit unserer
währung in verbindung bringt pain no
gain und da wir gehen leben leben wir
auch payne wir sind der samen warte was
richtig gehört wir sind der samen ohne
es armen
fangt an zu beten erreicht hast du den
einstieg in deutsch verpasst hast du den
einstieg in bitcoin verpasst dann sei
dieses mal schlauer und investiere alles
was du hast bin genau so hofft dass sein
das ding ist diese werbung muss auch
irgendwo zu finden sein
wir brauchen eine website wir hätten uns
eine menge aufwand damit machen könne
website von vorne bis hinten nicht zu
programmieren oder wir nehmen einfach
ein template das genauso aussieht wie
jede crypto sollte genau das haben wir
getan unter dem namen news.de kommt ihr
jetzt auf unsere krippe website die
sieht note eins zu eins aus wie jede eis
die man in den letzten drei jahren
gesehen hat wir sehen unseren
krankengeld wird 1769 und diversen
erklärungen wie unser köln funktioniert
würde euch aber raten die website selber
mal aus zu checken denn dort gibt es
einiges zu finden founder ceo und im
play-off wenn man also geht auf die
website ihr werdet einiges drin
ich würde fast sagen unser gesamtes
werbekonzept steht wenn man diesen könig
vertraut welchem dann in welchem der
marketingplan steht die website steht
das video steht wir haben
vertrauenswürdige verkäufer ab wir
brauchen nur noch den keulen das problem
ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung vom
programmieren ich habe keine ahnung was
es eigentlich für unterschiede gibt ich
verstehe das grundkonzept von crypto
aber wie erstellt man dass keine ahnung
natürlich habe ich auch nicht genug zeit
um mir jetzt das programmieren innerhalb
von vier tagen so beizubringen dass ich
eine krippe währung water zeit irgendwie
zusammen programmiert bekommen die ich
dann auch verkaufen kann also
hab ich mich auf die suche nach services
gemacht die mit dieser arbeit abnehmen
und was ich da gefunden habe man
komplett krank eine gute alternative zu
einem vernünftigen keulen und einem sehr
gut produzierten ist kein tool punkt ab
und als ich das gefunden habe bin ich
komplett komplett crazy gegangen das ist
eine website auf der man von den
gängigsten points also eher 10 20 wäre
terium bmi ist beides auf basis von
diesen kurs innerhalb von wenigen
minuten erstellen kann
ok token auf basis von points was zur
hölle habe ich da erzählt coins sind
eigenständige plattform mit kriterium
während beispiele dafür
anders sieht es bei den tokens aus die
quasi nur ableger von einem dieser
plattform sind was in der welt vom
crypto häufig reicht um irgendeine kasse
idee die in keiner weise funktioniert zu
vermarkten und zu verkaufen ich habe
mich ein bisschen informiert und ich
werde einen bmw also einen auf einen
basierenden tauchen erstellen und das
werden wir jetzt gemeinsam tun und ich
zeige euch wie fucking einfach es ist
und gleichzeitig dadurch wie gefährlich
das ist wenn ihr keine ahnung habt
genauso wie ich in irgendwelche complus
zu investieren denn jeder vollidiot kann
hier zeigen crypto token erstellt so und
wir sehen schon ganz oben das allererste
für das wir uns entscheiden müssen ist
der token nehmen jetzt können wir auch
endlich unseren namen premiere
und was würde besser passen als red
genau das soll dieser vornehmlich waren
er soll leute schnell reich machen oder
vielleicht auch nicht wir werden sehen
auf jeden fall trägt man hier einfach
den namen ein gate bridge wir überlegen
uns ein symbol also grf die abkürzung
dafür wir können uns entscheiden wie
viele es davon geben soll und ob sie
nachträglich noch zum einen sind wir
gehen einfach mal auf 10 10 millionen
was die hälfte von bigpoint ist und
diese information 18 dez malen das ist
so die standard crypto länge und dann
können wir uns entscheiden ob man welche
davon können kann also
stellen kann um zwei das ist alles
völlig egal wir wollen diesen tagen
einfach klären bevor ich jetzt auch
craig hogan dritte ihr müsst nichts
machen außer euch den namen zu überlegen
und zu überlegen wie viele davon haben
wollt den rest könnt ihr einfach so
stehen lassen wir drücken auf create
toten meine metermaß quad öffnet sich
jetzt seht ihr nichts mehr
jetzt muss ich einfach nur einfach nur
400 euro bezahlen für eine absolute
scheiße das werden wir jetzt aber machen
und sobald ich jetzt diese 400 oder 450
euro in büren wie bezahle werden sofort
zehn millionen mal gate bridge fast oder
save me oder was auch immer in eurer
wallet gutgeschrieben ihr habt die
instant die müssen nicht gemeint werden
die sind einfach sofort sagen das ist
komplett gestaltet er das ist komplett
gestört
wie schwer ist es eine clubtour währung
einen crypto trocken ins leben so toren
created successfully wir haben zehn
millionen gr
das so gestört dass bedeutet mann ist
zirka 23 minuten davon entfernt einfach
so für 450 euro seinen eigenen klub
trocken ins leben zu rufen ohne jede
ahnung der total fertig erstellt wir
hatten unseren marketing planen und ich
bin mir sicher dass wir es hinbekommen
würden denen jetzt auch zu verkaufen
dann habe ich mir die frage gestellt
braucht die welt einen weiteren tipp
krank braucht die welt einen weiteren
schritt können von mir grundsätzlich ja
aber ich sollte mich vielleicht erst
noch ein bisschen weiter über dieses
thema informieren und mich mit jemandem
zusammen tun der das wirklich
professionell macht ich glaube geld fast
hat nicht das zeug dazu irgend jemanden
in irgendeiner weise weiter 12 deswegen
habe ich mich dagegen entschieden diesen
zu verkaufen
diesen tagen zu kaufen hinzulegen
ich will niemanden von euch geld aus der
tasche ziehen dieser kryptischen kam
rein gar nichts schreibt einfach eure
rolle da die gäste ohnehin die
kommentare dann schick ich paar leuten
von euch einfach ein paar gate bridge
fast trocken rüber wenn ihr aber sehen
wollt wie ich mich um dieses thema ein
bisschen ausführlicher kümmern und eine
gute idee umsetzte das lassen die video
leichter wenn dieses video über 30
millionen
dann lasst ihn nicht rein lasst ihn
leichter wenn dieses video über 30.000
sax bekommt dann werde ich mich weiter
darum kümmern und einen freund mit
nutzen erstellen den bedarf auch
wirklich verkaufen ich bin unfassbar
rahmen des projektes megageil wir sehen
uns nächste woche wieder zu einer
weiteren folge rolex
wir fahren wir fahren nach paris keine
rolex trade up abonniert trotzdem damit
ihr das nächste video nicht verpasst wir
sehen uns macht's gut
[Musik]